[Music]
[Music]
what do you think is the biggest thing
standing between you
and the aegis our tour
and my current my curse no matter what
team he's playing on how many
tournaments he wins
he can never seem to win dota 2's
biggest prize
pg sorry but for them and
it's starting to look like it might
never happen
[Music]
artesi first joined eg in 2014 and
started making waves immediately
the midnight pulse and there's your jump
in universe good ravage
first fly call now gonna go but look at
the damage from artezy
he evaporates the enigma universe is
here and now he goes to excalibur
he's down two three lost they've almost
got to be the cheese pops and he just
nails the batter into play ultra kill
for arteezy
i think he's always had this reputation
of being one of the best especially when
he came on the scene it was a huge
splash you know he was
changing the way that carry players were
kind of looking at the game and
artur is one of those guys who's
maintained that success eg was doing so
well in fact that they received a direct
invite to ti4
and were even the favorites to win the
tournament they've got champion written
all over
evil geniuses and dk i think from the
group stages they just look
so solid yeah i think that's where like
with newbie eg and dk are the two other
teams do i look at and say these are
championship teams
but after losing to newbie in the upper
bracket and vichy gaming in the lower
artezi and eg packed their bags and went
home with their first of
many bronze medals they do bring down
artesia a second time
and now they go for the high ground here
and they get more they get the enigma as
well
beachy are cracking open this eg base
and it's gg they got too greedy and
vichy punish it again
what a way to go out but artesi didn't
lose
hope he left eg to join team secret and
played a new role
hard to carry he's already there
[Music]
secret was considered one of the best
lineups in the world
and yet it was artesi's old team eg
that lifted the aegis that year on the
run behind him the kid running out for
gg world
[Applause]
artesi was having second thoughts about
secret
so just days after ti he left the team
and rejoined eg
hoping to win the next international
with them when
i got replaced by smell and they won ti
i was like i smiled actually you know i
usually never smile when i
when even when i was like on secret and
we want to land i would just sit there
emotionless
even though i beat eg like two grand
finals i wouldn't really care
but then seeing like uh my old teammates
win like fear i think
he deserved ti win for sure so
seeing him win i would i'm gonna hold
back the jealousy and i was just smiling
leading up to ti6 artesi's individual
performance was
top notch but eg were having a difficult
time fitting him
into their play style because now they
have to split farm priority between
sumail
and artisi under 30 minutes
baker will eliminate eg and for the
first time
they don't find themselves in the esl
one final but eg like they they swap out
a
aui to bring in our tour and how was
that all gonna function
currently maybe a couple of bumps down
the road so artisi left eg
once again rejoining secret to play mid
but once he reached ti everything
fell apart there's a disruption from pi
but the boat comes in
he's down and secretly
eg meanwhile made it all the way to a
respectable third place
after jumping ships so many times in his
pursuit for a ti victory
artesi realized that the constant back
and forth wasn't really
getting him anywhere so he decided it
was time to settle down and grind it out
for a win our tour has been kind of like
the team hopper he left
and then he came back and then he left
again and
i think both times was like very
devastating
but by betting everything on eg artesi
suddenly had
another curse to deal with because eg
were doomed to practically always place
third at valve events it's looking to
turn it miracle runs in he gets the stun
up here but he's used up
he's kept out of the fight artis he's
gonna try to lock him down the echo
though
so through an artist fast gets chopped
off
he's down for the count no buy back for
a hundred universe could be next
gg oh gee
the green dream it lives on
now team liquid they just go up they
look to force it
they can sniff and they got fear caught
out with the behalf of us
there it goes you've lost everything pg
there really isn't a hope anymore
even universe burning it out there it is
team liquid
they will take it 2-0 against
evil geniuses and samael jumping on the
back lines
finds fly shallow grave will protect him
he needs a better target moving between
them the bkb timing wasted fly will be
able to drop
now and morph link heart fighting hard
xerox will drop down low
zai wants to finish him off but really
it's up to sumail if he can do any level
of damage or so over if gg
og have done it they're taken out but
once
ti champion and ergy will advance
to their third major grand final it's a
blade mill from artezy trying to step
the bleeding
but it's not happening another in the
grave eg
all out of focus in trouble and inside
their base
this is looking like it's going to be it
is sumail
last one alive for the team dead again
and gg
lgd are moving on to the grand finals
artesi's continued
failures were cosmic but his
determination
was stronger than anything but even like
back at ti6 when when i lost the first
thing i did when i got home is i just
played dota
i like got on my computer i just played
for like 12 hours straight at pubs and
i don't know i just like i don't think
i'll like take a break or anything which
is the weird part
maybe i'm just saying it now but i think
i just like the game so much that
even win or lose i'll still be happy
playing and finally
at esl one birmingham eg managed to
break their third place
curse the sorcerer's got nothing brought
down death for the whole time
that's really gg there is no more battle
there is nothing we're waiting just for
the call because this is the march
inevitability
there it is evil geniuses
lgd in that winner's bracket
final and they have broken the three
curse
and with their third place curse behind
them ti9 was bg's chance to show the
world that they were more than a one-hit
wonder
and it was artesi's chance to finally be
in the right place at the right time
his path to the aegis was clear victory
was closer than it had ever been
this is evil geniuses seventh
international
one ages three third place finishes
and they are looking hungry
for that ages once again or at least a
male and a s4 once again the rest of
course still wants to get there
first one unfortunately
he couldn't even crack top three and
that's easier just wondering
what do i do i'm beating my head against
a wall
well we have beating his blades against
my tower now miracle
back in again another searing chain gh
with a blink pick up
they've got some time buyback comes in
from montesi
as the avalanche from samael it's just a
nibble on the back of my control and we
here we go concoction again
back up together finish it in style this
game's over
there's no way eg can defend this
they've got no heroes there is no more
chances
liquid they win 2-0
versus eg eliminating them from the
international
and keeping this clean run through the
loan
tmz rng and now e
g not a game loss they are the lower
bracket kings
artesi's big win slipped through his
fingers
yet again it's crazy to think that a
player of artesi's caliber someone who's
considered one of the best players in
the world
has never made it to a ti grand final or
won a major i think uh artesia as well
as just
you know in general his performance over
the past few years has been
pretty consistently good um you know
he's
always been known as this top three top
five you know team
always been on those squads and i think
for me at least
uh that's kind of given him that pass
he's won you know i think over a dozen
lands
it's just he has been consistently good
he's just never won those big events
at this point artesi has tried all kinds
of things to make ti happen for him
from the practical to the superstitious
uh you're shaved
because you think that um every time you
you have this
beer on and then you just lose but this
time you think it's gonna be something
different
i think i kind of heard my mom yell at
me too much and i just decided you know
enough is enough um i just shaved it
oddly enough we lost the first time that
i shaved our first series against it was
ig we lost right away
but now we're picking it up maybe the
curse is gone the beard is gone you know
it's all good
and to add to our teases miss
misfortunes he has a really bad habit of
getting cliffed
something the community obviously turned
into a meme
they also lose the glitch he's on the
high ground he's stuck up on the high
ground and the avalanche the tots
they got him caught arteezy where are
you going to go cliff's up in trouble
but smart buys back he wants to deal
with damage but he can't do anything
they're too far away from him that
terror blade is stuck up there
and sumeo left all alone to his own
devices
they can't do anything at all where's
your damage it's up too high
they want to pull the fight back over to
this side of the engagement
but it's not happening he's still up
there evil genius is gonna lose their
carry in the most tragic of ways is
s4 just wants a little help but it's not
coming
oh no no no no no the torrent the abba
the toss
and the destruction there you go it's
right there so it's very easy to kind of
mid-team fight you think you're getting
worried
[Music]
right here
[Applause]
put it up but show him how it says very
easy as you can see
so it's like a it's an active item does
it have a cooldown or what yeah it takes
it takes three slots
but um yeah it does have a cooldown how
do you feel
moving forward do you think it will
positively impact uh the games
i think that means like against darkster
and bad rider i can just chill like
every time we take a fight on the high
ground i'll just chill i think this is
gonna i'll use my ladder
this is gonna win the tournament i think
so and of course it's
just a meme it's a harmless bit of
community fun but
it is another baffling roadblock in
artesi's quest for victory
but no matter what challenges he's faced
what obstacles he's overcome what
changes he's had to make artesi never
stops trying and if beating a curse is
what it takes to win the most
important tournament of his life artesi
will do
everything he can to make it happen
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages
you